the university of oxford is divided into
several colleges for simplicity's sake
think of them as harry potter houses
each college has its own living quarters
its own library its own dining hall etc
out of all the colleges that exist at
oxford this one the old souls college is
the most exclusive one you already must
hold a degree from oxford in order to
even qualify for application and if you
do qualify and apply you must go through
an examination process which has been
called the hardest exam in the world
there are even years when the college
doesn't admit anyone because no one was
deemed smart enough the exclusivity of
the college meant that it was often the
place where all the top brass of the
british empire came from in the late
19th and early 20th century the times
even called also's college a place for
running or helping to run the british
empire if you want to know more about
the history of the british empire and
its connection to the university of
oxford check out my video on it on the
mlaser history youtube channel